La volta al món a peu, dia 289.
Avui, dia molt important.
Intentaré creuar a peu la segona frontera més alta del món,
Kulmapas, que em farà sortir de Tajikistan i entrar a la Xina.
Ha fet una nit freda, però dintre la llurta s'estava bastant bé.
I, de fet, s'estava bastant bé que, mira, he sortit déu-n'hi-do,
l'hora que he sortit.
8 menys quart.
I, mira, no podria demanar millor dia
per intentar aquesta gesta de creuar a peu
la segona frontera més alta del món que aquest, eh?
De moment, no hi ha absolutament cap núvol.
D'acord? Allà, a la vista, potser a uns 1 o 2 quilòmetres,
crec que tinc el checkpoint que us vaig dir ahir.
A veure si tot va bé i, com a mínim, puc arribar fins al pas.
Checkpoint passat, cap problema.
Home, només m'han demanat el passaport, tu.
Mira que abans d'entrar a Tajikistan em van dir
imprimeix un munt de còpies del passaport, en vaig ser 8, de fotocòpies,
i també les mateixes fotocòpies del permís de la zona aquesta del Pamir.
I n'he donat dos.
Tinc aquí encara un munt de fotocòpies que, al final, no m'hauran servit.
No passa res.
Bueno, 0-20, està perfecte.
Ara, des d'aquí, són 25 quilòmetres
i 560 de desnivell positiu
fins a culmapàs.
Estic a 3.800 metres sobre el nivell del mar.
Una petita inclinació així ja fa que, si parlo, em costi, eh?
Però, bueno, també hi ha un gos que m'estava seguint.
Ara ja s'ha anat.
Sí, només em faltava això, un gos, ja,
per acompanyar-me fins a la gira.
aph
Està passat.
Urban democrat exercising
Està passant.
Les 11 i poc
porto 12 quilòmetres
queden 15 encara
i 400 i pico de desnivell positiu
per tant, la pujada forta
encara està per arribar
ara mateix estic als 3.900
i escaig metres
i allà darrere
en principi després d'aquesta
muntanyeta
doncs potser es pot veure allà
com a pas
i darrere meu
ja fan actar presència els núvols
aquest matí, bueno aquest matí encara és matí
però no hi havia cap i de cop i volta
sense
sense donar-me en compte
em miro al cel i dic ostres
bueno
cada
país pel que vaig
faig un resum del que més m'ha agradat
i el que menys m'ha agradat
que menys m'ha agradat de Tajikistan
a la Pols
evidentment
encara que ara fa bastants dies que
no em menjo tant de Pols
va ser sobretot aquell tram de la frontera amb Afganistan
sí
després la calor
tampoc m'ha agradat però bueno això no és culpa de Tajikistan
és que he vingut aquí a l'agost
i sí, jo a la meva volta amb una peu
pensava que el país on faria més
calor era Jòrgia
perquè l'any passat vaig estar
i a Cotes Baixes feia una calor que brutal
però per la ruta que vaig escollir
vaig escollir una bona ruta i no feia tant de calor
en canvi aquí a
a Tajikistan encara que aquests últims dies
han sigut més aviat de fred
la majoria del país ha sigut
patir bastant per la calor
prefereixo això d'ara
que per l'any passa una mica de fred
però pel dia s'està bé
que la calor que està brutal
bueno
i el millor
el millor de Tajikistan
bueno, top 3
ai, el menjar tampoc m'ha agradat, no sé si ho he dit
però el menjar massa monòton, massa avorrit
i no especialment bo, la veritat
el millor
top 3, els animals
o més aviat la manca d'animals
pocs gossos
i els gossos que hi havien
supertranquils
supertranquils que el problema
i tampoc hi havia ni mosquits ni mosques
per tant, si t'estona aquí a Tajikistan
tu en aquest sentit has sigut
genial, genial
no he tingut cap problema amb llops
ni amb lleopards de les neus
que n'hi ha en aquestes muntanyes
però guai
a les pujades m'ho feu
bueno, top 2, la gent
ha sigut una passada
i top 1
la sensació d'aventura
la sensació de dir, ostres, estic al cul del món
estic a
tants dies de distància de
de qualsevol ciutat
tants quilòmetres
el fet que aquí no vingui turisme normal
només vingui turisme de gent que
ve a fer això, una aventura
el fet de que
ningú, gairebé ningú, faci a peu
aquests paisatges
increïbles
que no són els més macos del món
però són molt únics
l'altre dia ho parlàvem a algun
on pots trobar un paisatge així?
doncs potser al Tíbet
però a pocs més llocs del món pots trobar un paisatge així
amb aquest altiplà
aquestes muntanyes tan seques
pot ser altes a la vegada
brutal
llavors això, sí
si voleu una aventura, veniu a Tajikistan
home, jo no us recomano
fer el que he fet jo
el que he fet jo és estar guai en cotxe
o en bicicleta
però si heu de venir a fer senderisme
anar
als llocs guais
en cotxe o com sigui
i després fer l'ascens als llacs
o als cois o als pics
a peu
bueno, deixo de parlar
que no puc més
doncs no, està cap allà
però no es veu exactament
perquè si es veiés es veuria algun tipus d'estructura
de la duana, de la frontera
tal, no es veu res
però cap allà, cap allà està
10 km
sense culmapàs, són les 12
i 11
oh
com està costant
fuà
ja
frontera
que s'està fent
derrogar eh
tant tot el país
com el dia d'avui eh
està costant eh, que Déu n'hi do
veieu allà?
allà no és
però allà com a mínim s'acaba la pujada
allà és com veurem culmapàs
mira
mira que bèstia
es comença a veure una de les arestes del
Mustak Ata
una de les 50 muntanyes més altes del món
en 7.500
metres sobre el nivell del mar
està al costat xinès
just després de
de la frontera, la tindrem davant dels nassos
brutal eh
això sí, com veieu
ja vaig bastant abrigat
ah, hi ha núvols, hi ha vent
i ben fred
vinga tu, cada cop més difícil
ara sí, ara sí
culmapàs
mireu quina
barbaritat de cua de camions
però què és això?
n'hi ha
moltíssims, mireu
aquí hi ha una mena de tanca
que aquí és una tanca
i aquesta carretera de servei, això no és culmapàs
això ja és la part xinesa
és una carretera de servei, però el pas
està just allà
i el Mustang Ata
malauradament no el podem veure perquè
hi ha aquests núvols
llàstima eh, perquè seria brutal
veure una muntanya de 7.500
metres ara mateix
fuà tio
bueno, sembla que està a prop però
a quatre quilòmetres i mig
encara
ostres tu
però tio, que bèstia
que bèstia aquest lloc eh
tots els camions
que m'he trobat
aquest mes i pico
a Tajikistan
sobretot les últimes 3-4 setmanes
el 90% venien aquí
venien a la Xina
per portar, recollir coses
i ara aquí estan, segur que n'hi ha algun
de camion que ha fet
el viatge d'anada i de tornada
i m'ha vist dues vegades
o potser n'ha fet dues vegades i m'ha vist quatre
hahaha
música
Com m'ha passat?
Ja està, ja està conod.
Que bèstia, tio!
Que bèstia!
Bones notícies, veig ja dos ciclistes, dos ciclistes estrangers, això és bona notícia.
Buah, que emocionant.
Hòstia, no m'ho esperava, no m'ho esperava aquesta emoció.
Buf, que bèstia tio, hòstia no, no puc parar, ai que m'atropella, com abast tio, buah,
que bèstia.
Buf, quina emoció eh, increïble tio.
Ara si 4.300 metres.
Buf, que emoció eh, increïble tio, ara si 4.300 metres.
Punt més alt de la meva vida, en fi, és que no, no cal dir res jo crec, moment molt
emocionant.
Bé, aquí em quedo, aquí em quedo amb el vídeo, ja no gravaré més endavant, perquè ja se
sap que les fronteres no es pot gravar normalment, i més aquesta frontera, la frontera més dura
que passaré a la volta amb una peu probablement, frontera més dura de la meva vida, potser
passada, i potser futura, també, eh perquè poques coses més extremes que aquestes hi ha, eh.
La fila de camions és brutal.
Buf, llestima, llestima que no els vegi al, el, com es diu, a la montanya aquesta.
Al Mustaq Ata.
Si no seria el colmo.
Buf, bueno, per si hi ha algú nou, doncs això, no gravo les fronteres.
i, bueno, la frontera consisteix
bàsicament en primer sortir
de Tadjikistan i després
entrar a la Xina, no? Sortir de Tadjikistan
no hi hauria d'haver cap problema
excepte
que la persona que em va fer
el visat, que vaig haver de pagar el diner, 190 euros
perquè em tramitessin el visat
d'urgència, una agència de viatges
de Tadjikistan, doncs
l'única cosa que podia passar és que
no em fes el visat de 60 dies
i m'enganyés, llavors
avui que és el dia 39, crec
doncs estaria sobrepersonant el meu visat
i per tant seré una aliada
però en principi això no ha de passar
un cop hagi sortit de Tadjikistan
suposo que hauré de caminar una mica
fins a la part xinesa
on
on, bueno, no sé si
em fan aquí el control
o a baix, la duana
i tot el tema del passaport
diria que és a baix, a la vall
llavors per això m'han de portar fins a vall amb un cotxe
però no sé
potser m'ho fan aquí dalt i un cop passat
tot el control, llavors em baixen a baix amb el cotxe
aquest tronc no el podré fer caminant
aquí és on
vindrà el registre de tot
de la motxilla, potser
em preguntaràs si tinc un visat, els diré que no
que no em cal perquè soc ciutadà
europea i tinc 30 dies gratis
sense visat a la Xina
pot ser que em revisin el mòbil
els vídeos
podria ser
no sé, jo igualment ara faré
una còpia de seguretat dels
d'això, dels vídeos
que he fet ara aquí a la frontera
els amagaré una mica dintre del mòbil
perquè no tal
però bueno, jo crec que al principi
no hauria de passar res
què més, ja està, un cop a baix
és quan
si hauria de tenir internet
hauria d'activar la meva SIM
que la vaig preparar abans d'ahir ja
la meva és SIM xinesa
i també tinc la LiPay
que vaig preparar
és a dir que puc pagar amb targeta a baix
clar, no tinc lloants
així en principi es paga tot amb targeta
llavors no hauria de tenir problemes
però bueno
després no sé si em faran pagar diners
per baixar-me fins a baix
tinc dòlars en aquest cas
vull dir que
i diners de Tadjikistan
encara que no crec que els valguin
doncs no crec que hi hagi cap problema
ens veiem a l'altra banda de la frontera
o en aquesta banda si no m'han deixat entrar
vinga, una, dos i tres
senyores i senyors
I'm in
aquí estic
China
Siiii
Uf, mare meva
quin patiment eh
ostres tu
m'ho han fet patir eh
que ja ho sabia
que aquesta era una frontera dura
perquè ho havia llegit a internet i tal
però uf
a vegades aquestes coses la gent exagera tal
no, no, no
gens exagerat eh
mare meva
ara us ho explicaré tot pas per pas
i doncs
Però, deixeu-me anar al restaurant-hotel, perquè aquí fa una rasca que flipes.
D'acord, primer problema.
Resulta que a l'hotel aquest només accepten el pagament per WeChat, cosa que jo no tenia ni idea.
Jo pensava que ho tenien per fer servir a l'Ipay.
I dic, merda, merda, no puc pagar.
Doncs en Jeremy m'ha ajudat i, a més, em convida a una brotxeta.
Doncs m'ha ajudat perquè ell ha pagat a l'hotel i jo he pogut pagar-li a ell amb l'Ipay.
Bueno, coses de Xina que jo no m'entero.
Bueno, genial.
D'acord, doncs ja estic aposentat.
Perdoneu-me que aquí he estirat el llit.
Potser no és la posició més decorosa, però és el que hi ha.
No hi ha cadires.
A veure, per començar, dic que no sé a quina hora visc.
Ara mateix marca aquí les 11, gairebé.
Però, clar, això, les 11 són a Pekín.
O sigui, aquí jo crec que l'hora adequada és l'hora de Tadjikistan.
Per tant, li he d'arrestar 3.
Per tant, és com si fossin les 8.
Les 8, està bé.
Jo, normalment, a Tadjikistan anava a dormir a les 10.
Està bé.
A Catalunya són les 5 de la tarda.
I aquí són les 11.
És que és molt louc.
És molt louc.
Bueno, va, vaig a explicar-vos el que ha passat,
perquè té tela, eh?
Ara serà llarg, això.
Bueno, primer de tot, sortir a Tadjikistan, cap problema.
Seguiu, vinga.
Adeu.
Ja està.
És Tadjikistan, ja està.
Entrada a la Xina.
Bé, per començar, dic que entre Tadjikistan i la Xina,
entre les dues fronteres,
hi ha una zona com zona de ningú, no?,
en la qual,
hi ha un munt de camions banyera,
un munt de cotxes d'aquests chemis elèctrics que portaven els cotxes.
Llavors, que ara ho he entès, o sigui,
tots els camions de Tadjikistan que venien carregats amb totes aquestes coses,
no anaven fins a la Xina a buscar-ho,
sinó que anaven aquí, a la frontera de Tadjikistan,
ho agafaven i després tornaven a Tadjikistan sense haver d'entrar per la Xina.
He vist algun camió de Tadjikistan que sí que entrava a la Xina, val?
Alguna mercaderia deuen venir a buscar aquí,
no?, però, en general, he vist que, doncs, els xinesos ho porten fins a dalt,
els tadjikistans ho recorrien i tal, val.
Llavors, després de la zona de ningú,
arribo a la frontera amb la Xina.
Com us he dit, aquesta frontera no la creu gaire bé cap a estranger
i s'ha notat perquè la primera persona que m'he trobat,
un home molt abrigat i amb la cara tapada, pel fred, suposo,
em mira el passaport, em pregunta si tinc un visat.
Aquí jo començo a patir, perquè, bueno, us recordo que si
ets ciutadà de l'Unió Europea i d'altres països, tens 30 dies d'avisat gratuït,
o sigui, sense avisar, o sigui, pots estar a la Xina 30 dies sense avisar.
I això inclou entrada per aeroports i entrada per fronteres terrestres, val?
Bueno, el tio aquest no en tenia gaire idea, llavors diu, acompanya'm, acompanya'm.
Parla amb un altre, vale, vale.
I després cap aquí.
Llavors em porten a una espècie de lloc una mica, bueno, no sé si sinistre,
però un lloc una mica raro, és com una nau industrial d'aquestes que es munten i es desmunten ràpid, no?
Però amb el terra de gravilla, o sigui, el terra era el terra natural.
Un lloc així una mica cutrillo, una oficina que tenien allà mig improvisada
i allà em trobo els dos ciclistes que m'he trobat anant cap al pas, no?
Ells anaven més ràpid i estaven primer.
I bueno, els estaven fent com una espècie d'entrevista, bueno, interrogatori podríem dir,
i estaven mirant les coses que tenien a la motxilla.
Cosa que ja us he dit que probablement bastaria, no?
Doncs sí, això ha passat a dalt del pas.
Llavors m'he hagut d'esperar uns bons 5-10 minuts i després m'ha tocat a mi.
Bueno, aquí jo ja estava nerviós pel tema aquest del visat, del senyor aquest i tal,
i el fet que tu entres allà i tu ja veus que és un altre món comparat amb Tajikistan.
Vull dir, els edificis, encara que sigui una zona així com molt inhòspita a 4.300 metres,
ja veus que hi ha més infraestructura, molta més infraestructura, molta més, d'acord?
Llavors entro allà i hi havia dues persones, un home i una dona.
La dona parlava anglès bastant decentment, però no diria 100% bé, tenia l'accent xinès,
que a vegades costa de pillar, i a més portava una mascareta, tots portaven una mascareta.
Llavors, clar, si no pots llegir una mica el que parles, a vegades és complicat.
Però bueno, crec que ens hem entès.
I bueno, per començar m'han fet passar la motxilla per un escàner
i després m'han fet treure tot el que portava a les butxaques
i m'han fet un catxeo bastant a fons, sense tocar, evidentment, coses que no s'han de tocar,
però m'han fet un catxeo a fons, tot bé.
I ha vingut la part que a mi em posava més nerviós, que era que em revisessin la motxilla.
I sí, m'han revisat la motxilla, ha sigut menys exhaustiu del que jo em temia.
Han tret un parell de bosses estanques i no s'han ficat més a dintre la motxilla.
La bossa estanca del sac d'ormi no l'han mirat, la tenda de campanya no me l'han fet treure,
la powerbank, que és una cosa que jo potser temia que me la pogués treure,
i si em treure, doncs no, no se n'han ni mirat.
Han mirat les butxaques de dalt, de baix, les piquetes, tal, res.
I bé, sí que és veritat que han obert la bossa d'un ticle d'electrònica
i allà han agafat el Garmin, l'Inridge, que és el comunicador per satèl·lit.
I m'han preguntat què és, i jo li he dit, és un comunicador per satèl·lit,
però quan no tinc cobertura poder-li enviar SMS als meus pares.
Que no és mentida, és això, no?
I bé, m'han preguntat si anava caminant, tal, la dona bastant simpàtica.
Hi ha algun moment que jo m'he volgut fer el simpàtic, també,
i no ha sortit del tot bé, perquè li he preguntat,
ei, i com es diu caminar en xinès?
I aquí no ens hem entès, perquè la paraula work, walk, walk,
clar, ells pronuncien work, treballar, també pronuncien walk,
perquè la R no la saben fer.
Llavors ella m'ha dit com si jo treballo aquí, tal.
Li he dit que és igual, no et preocupis, no et preocupis.
Doncs això ha durat una bona estona, i bé, clar, m'han enviat el passaport i tal,
però aquí no és el control de passaports, el control de passaports era a baix a la vall.
Us en recordeu que us he dit, no?, que em farien baixar a baix a la vall amb un transport.
I això ha sigut, bé, aquesta espècie de taxi, bé, no, taxi que m'han fet agafar,
jo ja sabia que era obligatori, s'havia de pagar,
però no es tenia molt clar la quantitat, no?
Llavors, clar, jo no tinc, jo no tinc iens, es diu ien, no?
O yuan, yuan, la moneda de la Xina.
Llavors, tenia, tinc dòlars.
Em diu, deu, deu dòlars per persona.
I jo, bé, bé, doncs trec un billet de set dòlars.
No té canvi, el tio.
Diu, no tinc canvi, i jo, ostres.
Acceptes so moni? Li dic a la moneda de Tajikistan, acceptes so moni?
Diu, sí. Ostres, tu, que bé, tu.
Que bé, perquè em sobraven so monis.
L'escandalós del tema és que saps quan et cobraves si pagaves en so monis?
40 so monis, per tant, 4 euros. Si pagues en dòlars, 10 euros.
Si pagues en moneda de Tajikistan, 4 euros.
No ho sé.
I els ciclistes han hagut de pagar el doble,
perquè era 40 per persona i 40 per la bici.
I també estaven com queixant-se perquè no volien fer aquell tram amb taxi.
Ells no s'havien investigat, però no sabien que hi havia un tram
que havies de fer obligatoriament amb bicicleta.
Inclús s'han posat a discutir amablement, per discutir amb els de la duana,
i jo pensant, tio, què és la Xina, tio? Aquí no els he convençut de res.
Si està prohibit, si et diuen que està prohibit, està prohibit, ja està.
Bueno, total, que al final el problema que tenien era que ells pensaven
que les bicicletes no cabien al taxi, i sí que cabien.
S'han posat una mica nerviosos perquè eren bicicletes bones,
llavors clar, ficar-les allà apilades és com que estaven una mica nerviosos,
però al final han capigut. El que no cabien eren nosaltres.
Hi havia quatre seients i ens hem hagut de ficar sis.
Però bueno, ens hem posat així i ja està.
No hi ha hagut més. Era com una miniforgoneta.
Hem estat xerrant amb aquests, i doncs la baixada,
la baixada fins a la vall, espectacular.
Espectacular perquè s'han anat els núvols i llavors sí que es veia el Mustakata,
la muntanya aquesta. Brutal. Llàstima que no m'han deixat fer fotos.
Ells han tret la GoPro i li han dit no, no foto.
Hi ha moltes fronteres que tenen això, no? Aquesta terra de ningú
en la qual està molt vigilat, en què hi ha tanques
i ganivetes d'aquestes molt altes i tal.
Aquesta normalment són 200 metres i aquesta han sigut 15 quilòmetres.
Bueno, coses de la Xina.
D'acord, un cop arribem a baix toca customs,
que és immigració, no? No sé com traduir-ho això.
I jo ja pensava que el pitjor ja havia passat, no? No.
No.
Bueno, entro jo primer perquè els de la bici havien de trobar la bici i tal.
I fico el passaport a la maquineta aquesta i després em diuen no, no, vine amb mi, vine amb mi.
Perquè és que no hi havia ningú, no hi havia absolutament ningú.
Llavors, clar, si hi havia 8 persones, 10 persones allà treballant
i no hi havia ningú i deuen passar molts pocs estrangers per aquell pas,
doncs clar, volen fer la seva feina bé, no?
Doncs, bueno, em porten a un lloc on em fan escanejar un QR.
Sort que la SIM la tenia activada i em funcionava internet.
Funcionava. 5G. 5G, xaval, per fi.
Doncs escanejar un QR on has de posar les teves dades.
No sé si heu fet algun cop una visa a una rival, una visa a l'arribar al país, doncs et fan escriure coses, no?
La teva ocupació, el teu número de telèfon, la teva ruta, no sé què, moltes coses.
Però això es fa així com online aquí a la Xina.
I per sort m'ho ha fet un. O sigui, m'ha agafat el mòbil i m'ho ha fet ell.
Un dels oficials m'ho ha fet. M'ha preguntat bàsicament el número de telèfon,
ha fet una foto del passaport i també m'ha preguntat el recorregut.
Llavors també ha vingut el... No parlava en anglès. Parlava en anglès només un i mig, podríem dir.
El jefe, el jefe del lloc parlava anglès.
I aquí és quan han començat a fer preguntes insistents d'on em quedaré aquesta nit.
Clar, jo no tenia res reservat, perquè dic, bueno, no sé, saps? No sé.
I ostres, jo no sé, tal. No els hi volia dir que volia acampar, evidentment. Això no els hi anava a dir mai.
Però els dic, bueno, potser vaig a Trash Congar o potser em quedo per aquí.
Per aquí em refereixo a aquesta guest house.
Que tampoc sabia si existia, jo diria que sí, però...
Total, que així, més donant-li llargues i tal, ho han acceptat, això.
I després està el tema del mapa. Mira, tant a dalt, tant a cul mapàs, com aquí, com allà a baix, aquí a les aduanes,
s'han fixat molt en la meva samarreta, que surt un mapa.
Jo pensava que al principi era simple curiositat, del pal.
Ah, mira, estàs fent la volta al món a peu, ah, que guai, que tal.
Però crec que no, eh.
Perquè a dalt m'han dit, ai, i la Xina on és? La Xina on és? Aquí?
I m'han fet com senyalar el mapa aquest, que és un esquema.
Si heu vist la meva samarreta, el mapa és esquemàtic, no surten les fronteres, ja ho hem marcat, saps?
Però jo, sí, la Xina aquí, no sé què.
I després quan he arribat a baix, com no parlava en anglès, hi havia un que tenia un aparell així, que servia per traduir.
Llavors ell parlava i sonava la traducció, primer en anglès i després m'ho feia en castellà.
I després jo podia parlar i ell escoltava la traducció.
I hi ha hagut un moment que m'ha preguntat, tens un mapa, saps a on vas?
Jo aquí he entès, bueno, si tu vas cap a Trescongar, doncs tens un mapa per saber per on has d'anar, no?
Pensava que et referia a això. No, no et referia a això.
Volia saber si jo tenia un mapa, qualsevol mapa, és igual.
I li dic, no, tinc mapa al mòbil.
I després em torna a fer el traductor i em diu, ensenya'm el mapa de la teva samarreta.
Jo tenia la jaqueta posada, amb la cremallega damunt, no se'n veia.
Per tant, li havien dit des de dalt, jo crec, des de culme, que venia un tio que tenia un mapa aquí.
Jo no tinc aquesta obsessió amb el mapa, però bueno, l'obro, sí, li ensenyo, com orgullós, la volta amb un peu, tal.
No li dic res de la volta amb un peu.
Però bueno, sí, que aniré per aquí, tal.
I es miren molt a Xina, em fan una foto, i jo, però per què feu una foto?
Em diuen, ah, no, no sé què, no sé què.
I aquí començo a sospitar.
I després les sospites es confirmen quan la noia ciclista que anava amb aquesta parella
li fan treure un mapa de paper que tenia i el miren amb detall.
Llavors, què crec que vol dir això? Què crec que ha passat aquí?
Crec que, bueno, a veure com ho dic.
La Xina té diverses disputes territorials, no?, en determinats llocs.
Especialment a l'illa de Taiwan.
I jo crec que ells volen saber si el mapa que portes, aquesta illa surt com a territori xinès o com a estat independent.
És la meva suposició.
Perquè jo no en tinc tanta, no en tinc tanta, tanta obsessió amb el mapa.
No? No ho sé. No ho sé.
En qualsevol cas, bueno, després de ja omplir això, tal, no sé què,
em tornen a preguntar una altra vegada on em quedaré, tal.
Em deixen passar.
I després ve, per últim, ja quan, bueno, em segella.
Pam. I jo ja dic, yes.
Yes, m'han segellat.
Però encara quedava una cosa que era com un altre control del que porto a la motxilla.
M'han fet una passada a la motxilla per un escàner i aquesta vegada, doncs, m'han preguntat,
m'han agafat la bossa de menjar, m'han preguntat si tenia menjar, els he ensenyat que tenia cacauets, sal i ramen.
La sal, clar, és una mica més sospitosa perquè, no?, és així com sal, però va, sal.
M'han deixat passar. No sé què m'han preguntat més.
M'han preguntat si portava no sé què. Ara no ho recordo.
Però, bueno, tu, i encara quan he sortit, que dic, va, ja he sortit.
Encara hi havia una altra porta on he hagut de tornar a deixar el passaport i els he hagut de dir on anava.
És que no ho entenc, tio.
I els he dit, del guesthouse.
Ah, vale, allà, allà, allà, després de cinc minuts.
Ah, allà, ah, vale, ok, ok. I m'han deixat sortir.
I ja està. I aquí estic, per fi, a la Xina.
No sé si s'ha pogut explicar una mica el que he sentit, però sentia bastants nervis i angoixa tot el dia.
I angoixa tota l'estona.
Perquè, doncs això, no tenia molt clar si aniria bé o no.
És que jo mai he tingut una frontera amb tant d'escrutinis, que ha sigut bèstia, eh.
Molt bèstia, eh.
Jo estic segur que la frontera, altres fronteres terrestres, no són així.
Aquesta, doncs no sé per què és així. Bueno, ja ho he explicat diverses vegades, el per què.
I ara he arribat a aquesta guesthouse i he sopat.
He sopat.
Gràcies al Jeremy.
Ara hauré de fer-me el butxat, perquè si necessito...
Jo pensava que només podia pagar l'IPEI, però m'hauré de fer el butxat.
I què més? I després he menjat, doncs, uns noodles.
És a dir, uns noodles amb una salsa que li fiques per sobre, amb verdures i vedella.
Tampoc res de l'altre món. Si ho mengés a Barcelona, diria, bueno.
Però aquí, després de menjar tot el menjar tejic, m'ha sabut, m'ha sabut, és a dir, m'ha sabut a glòria.
Boníssim, boníssim.
I després, just després de... quan estava una estona allà, han vingut els altres dos ciclistes, que també es queden aquí aquesta nit.
La meva idea avui era, potser, caminar 10 o 15 quilòmetres, acampar,
i després així poder demà arribar a Trescongar, que està a 60 quilòmetres.
Així ja tenia una distància de 10, ai, de 50 o 45 quilòmetres.
Però m'han intimidat tant els d'immigració i tal, on em quedava tal, que no...
He dit, és igual, saps? Em quedo aquí, demà ja veurem caminant per la carretera o el que sigui, demà serà un altre dia, saps?
I ja està, avui, bueno, he dividit el dia en dues etapes, però no us més ensenyo la primera,
perquè la segona és des d'immigració fins aquí, que han sigut, què, 300 metres?
27 quilòmetres, 600 i pico de desnivell positiu, cabra fresc, ara pres té, i m'he gastat, doncs, 4 euros del taxi,
i això m'ha costat 20... 22 euros, crec, aquesta habitació.
I el sopar, 24, potser. Bé, bé, bé, però sí que és veritat que la dutxa...
La dutxa, ara m'he dutxat ja, però bastant fastigosa, no m'han donat ni tovallola.
La dutxa era, a la vegada, lavabo i feia una mica de pudor, algú havia estat allà.
Llavors, bueno, m'he dutxat, m'he mullat allà per plantejar una mica, i sí, m'he pogut dutxar, m'he pogut tirar sabó, i tot bé, i aigua calenta,
i bé, no?, però... A la Xina hi ha bons allunyaments, vull dir, aquest és que és l'únic que hi ha, aquesta zona.
Aquesta zona és l'únic que hi ha, i ja està, però jo crec que hi haurà bons allunyaments a Trescongar, i econòmics, i cap problema.
Bueno, tu, doncs ja està, ja està. Espero que hagi quedat clar una mica el que hi ha.
Demà què faré? No ho sé. Bueno, caminar, però no sé molt bé on anar, que demà ja ho veuré.
Un dia... un dia per recordar, eh? Mare meva, tio.
Un dia per recordar.
Un final feliç, al final, i ara la preocupació és la visa de Pakistan.
Però bueno, ja això, ja començaré a pensar demà.
He arribat a la Xina. A peu. Estic a la Xina.
Tu pots creure?
La volta al món a peu, senyors i senyors. Bona nit.
Bye, bye.
Bye, bye, bye, bye.